in this video I want to talk about some
important I mean
and modifications in proteins so some
amino acid R groups can be modified
after the amino acids are incorporated
in proteins and this can have impacts on
that protein structure and function so
I'm going to talk about four different
you know add some modifications in this
video and now so let's get started so
the first one is phosphorylation so
amino acids with H groups or hydroxyl
groups in their side chains which
include serine II Sarah named serine
threonine and tyrosine okay they can be
phosphorylated which basically means
that they can have phosphate groups
added or a phosphate group added to them
and the phosphorylation of proteins can
be done by two different types of
enzymes the first ones are kinase is and
kinase is what they do is they add a
phosphate group specifically from ATP or
from gtp to the protein that they are
phosphorylating um a phosphorylation can
also be done by phosphorylase --is sauce
for releases and the difference between
them in kinase is that phosphorylase is
add an inorganic phosphate which is just
free phosphate group and they add to the
protein and just as a note there are
enzymes that can remove those phosphate
groups and they are called phosphatases
phosphatases they can remove phosphate
groups via hydrolysis so here's another
an example of what's going on is that
we've got serine here and it has it is
Oh H group right there and that OS group
is what allows searing to be
phosphorylated so upon the addition of a
phosphate group whether that comes from
an ATP or GTP or even an inorganic
phosphate what we end up with is a sort
of phosphorus Terry in here so we end up
with an O P o 3 2 - and so that's kinda
what happens and I'm just showing it
here with serine but if this searing was
part of a protein that would alter that
protein structure and this can also
occur for 3 neens
Oh a screw-up or tyrosine Zoe's group
and phosphorylation is to be important
because it alters protein activity and
times the last students if
phosphorylation activates proteins or
enzymes and they almost always say yes
and it's not exactly entirely wrong but
it's not entirely correct either because
a lot of the times the addition of a
phosphate group does activate a protein
or an enzyme but sometimes the addition
of the phosphate group deactivates
protein or enzyme and so there's no
telling necessarily whether it activates
or deactivates something that you
typically have to kind of just know
about that specific case there's no
one-size-fits-all answer the I guess the
one-size-fits-all answer would be that
sometimes activate sometimes deactivates
which is not entirely clear but the
point is simply that it modifies the
structure of the protein specifically at
the sites of serine threonine and
tyrosine Zoe's groups and turns them
into phosphate groups so that is
phosphorylation all right next up
oxidation so oxidation basically
cysteines by all groups or the SH groups
they can be oxidized to form covalent
disulfide bridges or disulfide bonds
between cysteine residues so here I've
got two cysteine residues on the left
and you'll notice these little
squigglies here that's just an indicator
that there's more to the peptide chain
than just these cysteine so you can
imagine this as being part of like a
protein or something you know so if I
have this cysteine and maybe that
protein like continues around and
there's something like this going on I
don't want to get too messy but if you
place if there's an oxidizing
environment or an oxidizing agent what
can happen is that you can form a
disulfide bridge or that sulfide bond
which is a covalent bond between those
so the sulfur atoms in those residues
and so we could form a bond like this
and that is specifically the disulfide
bond or the disulfide bridge that we're
talking about which is a covalent bond
between those systems that's what I
sulfide bridge or disulfide bond okay
and that is a does a really good job of
holding proteins together oftentimes
it's really really important in doing so
now that can be disrupted and broken by
reducing environment
reducing agents and so if I added a
reducing agent here that would take it
right back to freestyle groups and so an
example so a reducing agent that can
destroy that del sulphide bridge is a
beta mercaptoethanol mercaptoethanol
it's also called to mercaptoethanol
that's a reducing agent that can destroy
I think I just wrote gent gentleman
reducing agent that can disrupt and
destroy those disulfide bridges
okay so phosphorylation oxidation of the
first two amino acid modifications other
concur that can occur in proteins
you